winter season is still in full force so
it's important to stock up on those
health and wellness products and who
better to show us the must-haves than
Don McCarthy of Don's corner thank you
so much for being here Don I'm so
excited and you're my beauty girl so
we're going to start off with some
winter Beauty so this is a company
called blue lean.com and what I love
about this company is it's outperforming
retinol so for a lot of people they
can't really use a retinol product
because it's Sun sensitivity or they get
irritation yes so this does not it has a
secret ingredient methylene blue and it
was created by a scientist that that
challenges and studies the aging process
so think of like Benjamin you know
button how time went back going
backwards in time this is what this does
they have creams they have everything
for the face but I'm loving their body
fix because it's obviously cool in
Winter out right now so I literally
slather this all over my body from my
back of my legs to the front of my legs
everywhere this is their body fix they
have great night creams they have a
whole plethora of stuff I absolutely
love it and it double your own collagen
and elastin oh my God so you're gonna
have to try that that's a must try I
love this now for our Foodies during the
winter time this is one of my new
go-to's this is streusely.com and it's
granola redefined there's no fillers
sweeteners grains it contains fiber
prebiotics healthy fats and superfoods
it's plant-based and gluten-free so they
have a cacao right here and and coffee
so I'm going to give you that so we can
kind of take a peek a look at that and
I'm going to actually give you some
stuff what I love about this granola
it's different than anything else out
there because it's sweet and savory so
you can put this on salads you can put
this on Avocado toast you can put this
on yeah if you want to put this as their
normal regular one I'm gonna just
sprinkle a little bit on top of it here
take a bite into that it's absolutely
delicious it's superfoods all in one
it's going to elevate your oatmeal I did
it right in front down here with some
yogurt but again amazing is that not
amazing I add it to my salads when you
go to a party add a little bit of this
and you can even get this on Amazon or
seriously dot com I'm going to keep
eating this in the package yeah it's
amazing but I'll let you keep talking
while I haven't forget about vitamins
and supplements this is jarrow this is I
don't know if you know this but this
year be you and it's all about B12 and
so methylene B12 is a little bit
different than the normal B12 because
it's absorbed a little bit different at
the cellular level it's going to support
your energy and the levels that you have
I'll go because we all think like B12
take it it's going to give you energy
yes but this even goes a little bit
deeper than that and it actually helps
your brain and nerves needed to actually
help function on a daily basis so
definitely take and take care of
yourself with some B12 jarrow has a
number of supplements that are top grade
but I really like this again this is
under 12 and this is something that you
need and it's great for older people
younger people I take it every day
they're just really easy to do they're
just little you can even take one
right now
but it doesn't even help you sleep as
well I think this is great all right
let's move on because we got a lot of
stuff but I'm loving this right now okay
what's over here this is espan habon and
if you didn't understand what I just
said in Spanish it is soap sponge so
this company has been around for decades
and this was created by Emilia smecca
and what I love about this guess how
many views this espon habon has on Tick
Tock I know it is trending it has a lot
over
220 million views so it's a soap sponge
it's great it has a plethora of again
just different scents I've got the aloe
vera down there they've got a melon I
love the Pearl is one of my favorites
they've got a charcoal for the men JC
you can get this at Walgreens or CVS
Emos it's two in one they have six cents
under five dollars wow
yoga purse I'm gonna have you put this
one on this one is their other little
carrier and look at Pop they've got a
little thing that you can put your purse
and stuff in but this is a Las Vegas
made company and this was created by
Angela Bliss and she's a Serial
entrepreneur she has several different
different companies this woman is
amazing she created this bag for herself
there's all kinds of great Pockets
inside of it it's stylish it's
functional it's a bag that you can carry
all your Essentials and go to your next
yoga class it comes in unique colors and
designs because she makes them herself
do you take yoga I do this is amazing
usually walk in holding all my stuff
like trying to and now I have like a
little bag and stuff like that so again
these are all just great to keep you
well and healthy for the winter time
thank you so much Don you have so many
helpful tips on social media just look
up Don's Corner you'll find all of her
stuff thank you so much for being here
I'm off to yoga